voilà un jeune élu engagé à la suite de
son grand père la passion de la
politique se transmet tel en famille
est-ce que cela n'empêche pas d'autres
jeunes d'émerger ou bien au contraire
faut-il se réjouir que cela suscite
ainsi des vocations et d'ailleurs est il
vraiment une crise de l'engagement
politique dans la jeunesse française ou
bien la politique s'exerce-t-elle
désormais sous d'autres formes
voyez que ce film dans les pas de son
grand mère de jean rené chapron nous
ouvre à beaucoup de questions et pour
approfondir à présent j'accueille rémy
cardon bonjour vous êtes sénateur
socialiste de la somme
à 26 ans vous êtes le benjamin du sénat
à vos côtés jean philippe dugoin clément
bonjour vous êtes maire udi de mennecy
dans l'essonne
je précise que l'un et l'autre vous avez
vous faites partie de familles d'élus
vous nous en direz plus nous sommes
également avec laurent l'art de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sociologue chargé
d'études et de recherches à l'institut
national de la jeunesse et de
l'éducation populaire et bonjour avoue
camille etienne vous présentez comme
activiste pour la justice sociale et
climatique vous êtes une ancienne de
sciences po engagé donc dans les
associations les ong et vous nous direz
pourquoi la politique pour vous ce n'est
pas seulement l'engagement partisan ou
électorale alors je vais commencer par
vous rémy cardon je vais vous demander
très simplement si vous vous retrouviez
dans ce qu'on vient de voir cette
découverte de la politique dans tout ce
qu'elle peut avoir à la fois de très
excitant et puis de sérieux parfois d'un
peu âpre oui dans ce documentaire c'est
vrai que je me suis un peu retrouvée
aussi dans le personnage du jeune qui
est élu avec son grand père j'avais un
rapport différent c'est mon père était
élu également ma mère aussi été engagé
j'ai effectivement fréquenté à la fois
les manifestations très tôt sur le sur
les épaules de mon père par exemple
et puis petit à petit j'ai choisi mon
chemin et figurez-vous c'est le même que
celui de mon père dans le jir et dans le
parti politique vous avez choisi
vraiment oui tout à fait puisque j'avais
une grande liberté d'ailleurs je n'étais
pas dans la même le même courant ou la
même motion que vont perdre le propose
le parti socialiste si vous les abris là
j'avais un vrai choix après j'ai fait
aussi le j'ai regardé ce qui se faisait
ailleurs par curiosité
et puis après voilà c'est aussi on a été
éduqué à la certaines valeurs et donc
forcément parfois ça ça se retrouve jean
philippe dugoin clément je vous pose la
même question vous retrouvez dans ce
qu'on vient de voir
oui c'est un beau documentaire parce que
ça montre tout simplement un parcours
humain parcours d'engagement de
quelqu'un qui démarre dans la vie qui
démarre un parcours de vie et je trouve
que le documentaire a été assez
intéressant parce qu'il a mis de côté ce
qui est l'appartenance partisane ou bien
souvent il ya aussi des à côtés ça c'est
vraiment focalisé sur le parcours de ce
jeune homme qui a envie de s'engager de
données pour l'autre qui découvre aussi
même s'il a un parcours il attaché
parlementaire par ailleurs donc ils
découvrent pas complètement la politique
mais entre intellectualiser quelque
chose et le vivre au quotidien
particulièrement dans une commune il y a
un écart extrêmement fort et c'est ce
volet là que j'ai trouvé très
intéressant le documentaire camille
etienne vous qui êtes engagé
différemment je le disais dans dans
l'action publique
est-ce que voilà cette vie d'élu ça vous
fait envie avec je le disais à la fois
tous ses côtés très passionnant de
rencontres avec les avec les sites les
concitoyens mais parfois aussi la protée
de la décision mais je suis ravi que
certains c'est pas tout acheter
on a besoin de plus en formes langage
est consciente et s'il peut y avoir déjà
8 de portée des décisions dans le plus
grand qu'eux mêmes
après je pensais signer il faut que ces
jeunes là et aussi le risque de
transformer cette 5ème république qu'est
l'eau qu'elle incarne un peu plus bas la
démocratiques d'aujourd'hui pour moi
elle est un petit peu fait bruit que
nous qui sert que de ne double pas à
cette double responsabilité pour nom
savant work leurs idées avec
l'intransigeance fait je passe passe
aussi peut-être à la difficulté d'être
jeune et beau parfois avec
condescendance et en tout le temps de
changer les balises les règles pourquoi
il est présent plus de la parole
démocratique soit entendue plus
l'argument le regard de cette situation
qu'on voit dans le film d'un élu d'un
jeune élu qui gisait y voit là on lui
met le pied à l'étrier c'est son grand
père qui lui met le pied à l'étrier
c'est fréquent on a beaucoup de d'élus
qui sont eux-mêmes fichou petit-fils dé
lui alors oui c'est une effectivement
une recherche que nous avons réalisés en
ahidjo près de 4800 jeunes les élus
municipaux de 18 à 35 ans effectivement
on voit qu'il ya une part conséquente de
jeunes élus municipaux donc 30% qui ont
un père ou une mère qui avait déjà été
élu municipal par le passé et donc plus
on monte aussi dans la hiérarchie mise à
niveau des moeurs et des maires adjoints
et tuent les chances aussi de trouver un
parent et u augmente donc effectivement
il ya un effet héréditaire de filiation
très fort
qu'est ce qui se pourrait que c'est
celle que la passion de la politique et
se transmet voilà très facilement en
famille le de chanter avec moi le montre
très bien les témoignages sur plateau
également mais au delà d'avoir un parent
déjà élu en réalité ce qui compte avant
tout les plus largement c'est d'avoir
grandi finalement dans un environnement
familial politisé pas nécessairement
d'ailleurs il est parent élu d'ailleurs
et donc d'avoir bénéficié d'une
surexposition familiale à la politique
qui va leur permettre ensuite de
connaître les différentes règles du jeu
politique ses codes ses filons ses
stratégies ses esquives et donc de
bénéficier aussi des connaissances
techniques sociales politiques pour
briguer un mandat et surtout pour
surtout se sentir autorisé à le faire et
ça c'est très inégalement distribuées
dans les cités françaises aujourd'hui et
je posais la question de savoir si
c'était pas un petit peu injuste à
l'égard de ce qui est une belle ne
bénéficient pas de cet apprentissage
accéléré
laurent l'art de bain effectivement
les inégalités très fortes en termes de
socialisation politique donc dans l'axé
au mandat on va voir qu'à des inégalités
notamment en termes de classe sociale on
sait que la socialisation politique se
transmet d'abord et avant tout dans des
familles souvent plus avantagés
socialement et scolairement
professionnellement économiquement ce
qui va conduire à reproduire dès le
départ ses inégalités
l'accès est également des inégalités
c'est important en termes de genre
aussi c'est à dire que la socialisation
politique la transmission de valeurs
politiques au sein de la famille est
encore surtout une affaire d'hommes avec
un modèle masculin dans la transmission
aux politiques ce qui n'est pas sans
effet ensuite sans conséquence sur le
fait que les jeunes hommes se sont
finalement davantage autour de 10 et à
se lancer dans un mandat municipal que
les jeunes femmes
je voudrais que vous vous entendre là
dessus l'un et l'autre rémy chardon et
jean philippe dugoin clément voilà on
vient d'entendre les codes les filons
vous avez bénéficié d'un voile d'une
formation accélérée grâce à votre
ascendance nord objectivement je crois
pas vraiment après au même titre qu'il
ya des familles où vous y retrouve des
familles d'enseignants des familles de
deux soignants des familles d'artistes
il ya une sensibilisation de sensibilité
qui existe parce que vous grandissez
dans un environnement est effectivement
vous pouvez avoir soit un phénomène de
rejet soit au contraire un phénomène
d'intérêt qui se fait à ce prix vous
avez ce sentiment projet par me levant
j'ai eu les deux bien sûr bien sûr que
quand vous êtes adolescents que votre
père est élu et que parfois vous avez
des enseignants qui confondraient de
prénom avec celui de votre père c'est
des choses qui qui marque donc vous avez
des peuvent vous avez une possibilité de
rejet puis vous avez aussi un regard qui
est différent c'est vous n'êtes pas sur
quelque chose sur la relation mandat
politique à l'engagement politique qui
est neutre
alors après c'est pas pour autant que
vous aller en chercher à en faire une
carrière en faire un engagement en faire
une
une volonté de fer pour les autres mais
vous n'êtes pas neutres par rapport à
quelque chose mais le le phénomène
d'intérêt ça il est réel après sa marque
plus en politique on le remarque plus en
politique parce que vous avez par
exemple personnalité du nombre quand on
le regarde on le trouve dans beaucoup de
domaines de la société rémy chardon vous
êtes senti favorisée par moments
favorisées
oui et non parce que des fois je vais
aussi des remarques par exemple sur le
népotisme
par exemple si vous êtes le fils de donc
je peux pas dire qu'on a été favorisé là
où on peut éventuellement assumer qu'on
a été un peu favorisés c'est
essentiellement ce fait qu'on se
retrouve dans deux des rencontres dans
des débats dans des manifestations plus
plus facilement parce que effectivement
nos parents ils sont présents laurent
dard de par l'aide des codes
voilà c'est que c'est quelque chose avec
laquelle vous avez été familiarisés très
jeune mais les codes de la peau mais
l'école ça s'apprend je dirais et j'ai
beaucoup de rencontres c'est aussi en
fonction des rencontres ce qui est des
jeunes qui ont pas forcément les parents
qui sont intéressés à la politique
qu'ils vont trouver un intérêt dans dans
l'éducation nationale petit à petit en
s'impliquant dans les cvl ensuite en
montant en s'investissant dans une
association et petit à petit vont tout
simplement se rendre compte que ça a du
sens et puis encore il faut le rappeler
la politique c'est la vie de la cité
un jeune qui fait organise un tournoi de
foot dans son lycée il fait aussi fils
fait vivre son lycée ben c'est ce que je
disais quand j'étais lycéen précédent
puisqu'il est très jeune donc ça
commence très jeune camille etienne on
parlait de voile à l'éveil à la
conscience politique qui était peut-être
plus facilement effectivement dans les
familles d'élus mais je crois que vous
nous parler de votre famille parce que
je crois que c'est aussi en famille
concon s'éveille à la politique même si
on fait pas forcément partie d'une
famille d'élus c'est votre cas en fait
ce que j'ai pu être un petit peu avec
les précédentes interventions sélection
privilège c'est à dire que on a en moi
j'ai réalisé que le fait de grandir son
que faire le parallèle aux portes du
parc national de la vanoise donc d'être
vraiment de m comme la nature et 2d très
tôt senti belyzel ça c'est un privilège
et ce qui fait que y en a d'autres qui
n'ont pas eu cette chance d'avoir accès
au site aux que moi l'information et
donc ça me donne une responsabilité
donc en fait pour moi il faut quand même
reconnaître que il ya bien sûr et des
parcours de vie il ya des ya des mais
voilà on va avoir des vocations qui vont
naître est désormais très forte mais il
ya structurellement
une une reproduction aussi des élites
qui se fait par des conditions
économiques et des conditions sociales
et donc ça ça existe et ça vient aussi
dans un privilège pour moi c'est
nécessaire de reconnaître ce privilège
là parce qu'après ça veut dire assumer
sa responsabilité et donc faire en sorte
dans une position de donner accès en
plus de monde possible
moi quand je le fais sur l'écologie je
sais que pas grand monde a eu la chance
d'avoir accès à autant d'informations
mois scientifique sur l'urgence à 22 ans
et donc du coup je vais prendre la
responsabilité pour former vulgariser le
plus possible de gens pour qu'ils
puissent avoir cette chance plutôt donc
pour moi laurent lardeux on faisait la
liste en préparant cette émission des
noms qui sont associés voilà aux
familles politiques en france alors on
parle des défis scar destin debré
poniatowski martine aubry jacques delors
la famille le pen bien sûr aussi est ce
que vous diriez qui a in voilà une
tentation dynastique dans la politique
en général et plus spécifiquement en
france pour tentation dynastique je ne
sais pas c'est vrai que c'est c'est
plutôt un environnement politique en
tout cas qui va qui va jouer mes tantes
à souligner c'est que ça signifierait en
tout cas qu'il ya presque une
automaticité finalement de la filiation
et la transmission et politique ce qui
n'est pas le cas en tout cas ce qu'on
voit plutôt et c'est plutôt qu'à une
socialisation politique de façon plus
générale et qui va jouer qui peu
imprégnés effectivement c'est ces jeunes
prétendants tentation on voit bien dans
le film que c'est un peu ambivalent mais
le grand père il est très heureux que
son petit-fils s'intéresse à la
politique donc quelques paris il est
heureux et c'est tentant pour lui voilà
de lui mettre le pied à l'étrier et
c'est en ce sens que je l'entendais
oui effectivement parce que aussi sans
doute parce qu'il ya très peu de jeunes
maintenant à
typé à la vie démocratique au niveau
représentatif en tout cas et du coup il
ya peut-être une tentation effectivement
des élus plus âgés de tenter de
faciliter l'accès aux plus jeunes et
notamment que le voir dans leur propre
famille donc ça peut sans doute jouer
parce que ce qui ce qu'on relève surtout
aujourd'hui c'est qu'effectivement il ya
un vieillissement accrue quand même de
de la politique traditionnelle mais
vraiment traditionnels c'est intéressant
parce que c'est une des questions que je
veux aborder avec vous maintenant et qui
est abordé dans le lean vrai qu'on
regarde un court extrait parce que le
maire dont on parlait à l'instant
bernard baudoux le grand-père de notre
jeune élu municipal il répond à 7 à
cette critique sur la question du voile
à du favoritisme familiale regarder on
en parle après j'ai pas choisi beau j'ai
envie de dire il s'est choisi tout seul
moi je n'ai pas choisi parce qu'à ce
moment-là gg j'en ai dix de petits
enfants j'aurais pu voilà mais non mais
non c'est lui qui s'est choisi parce que
il a fait partie de ces jeunes trop peu
nombreux seront peu nombreux quines
effectivement aujourd'hui ont décidé de
s'investir dans la politique
alors laurent l'art de cet argument les
jeunes sont trop peu nombreux il et il
est valable à vous nous disiez qu'il y
avait effectivement moins de jeunes qui
s'engagent dans la politique
représentative oui voilà effectivement
il y en a de moins en moins en tout cas
on sait que les jeunes mères par exemple
de moins de 40 ans sont sont très peu
nombreux il ya seulement 4 % de mer
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont moins de 40 ans
il est très faible comparativement plus
de 60 en revanche qui sont quant à eux
nettement majoritaires ils sont 55% de
mer dans cette tranche d'âge donc avoir
plus de 60 ans et l'âge moyen d'un maire
aujourd'hui c'est cinquante neuf ans
donc un âge qui ne cesse de s'élever
depuis maintenant une bonne trentaine
d'années fait que les plus âgées
occupent les places plusieurs plusieurs
causes à cela il ya d'abord une défiance
toujours plus forte des nouvelles
générations envers le personnel
politique défiance qui s'est d'ailleurs
accru ces dernières années comme le
montre très bien leur enquête européenne
sur les valeurs ils sont très peu
nombreux à adhérer à un parti politique
seulement 2 % des 18-29 ans à deir un
parti politique qui sont aussi plus
abstentionniste plus en retrait de la
politique traditionnelle
mais la politique pas de la politique
dans un sens plus large ans et je pense
qu'on y reviendra
on peut aussi expliquer ce retrait par
un cycle de vie aussi marquée par une
instabilité statutaire c'est l'âge du
premier emploi qui est devenu aussi le
plus en plus fragile incertain pour les
jeunes c'est l'âge de la mise en couple
de la parentalité
c'est donc ils ont peu de temps
finalement commencé à créer aussi pour
une fonction qui nécessite un certain
ascétisme et une grande disponibilité
ensuite il ya aussi une autre raison
alésia ces listes et des difficultés
aussi sans doute à convaincre aussi un
électorat et des élus souvent nettement
plus âgés avec des représentations qui
sont négatives persistantes sur la
jeunesse
il aurait demandé aussi bon de devoir
faire leurs preuves pour combler un
déficit de notoriété ou encore pour pour
surmonter une absence supposée
d'expérience ou de compétences alors
beaucoup de choses dans ce que vous
pouvez nous dire beaucoup de données
très intéressante et voudrait faire
réagir les deux élus qu'on a ici en
plateau peut-être d'abord sur cette
question de la crise de vocation la
difficulté de s'engager en politique
quand on est quand on est jeune on
manque de temps et puis parfois
effectivement on n'a pas une très haute
idée de la vie électorale
vous avez en les questions du temps dans
le reportage et il montre aussi que il
le dit clairement il rentre chez lui à
21h et quelques il a lui dit voilà c'est
aussi beaucoup de sacrifices c'est des
réunions qui finissent tard c'est comme
dans d'autres engagements 1,4 dans le
sport dans la culture c'est partout
pareil
et ça c'est vrai que quand on est jeune
et qu'on bat on à la recherche d'un
premier emploi on est à la recherche de
deux doigts de découvrir la société
c'est vrai qu'on se diront doute des
bons et ce que je trouve pas un emploi
d'abord et ensuite peut-être suis-je
pour gage mais bon au final le maquis
qui vont les deux il ya la question des
légitimités aussi parce que je rappelle
que vous êtes le benjamin du sénat 26
ans
vous êtes élu donc par des grands
électeurs qui sont sans doute son plus
c'est vrai que là dessus pendant toute
la campagne ça a été dur d'expliquer
qu'un sénateur peut avoir 26 ans c'est
une vocation c'est de figurer ou pendant
un mois j'ai dû essayer en tout cas et
dans ces cas-là grave juste en quelques
mots votre argument vos arguments votre
argumentaire en fait une question de
volonté c'est pas une question d'âge
majeur aujourd'hui être parlementaire
on peut être parlementaire très tôt si
on a à la fois le dirai pas ce que avoir
de l'expérience qu'est ce que ça veut
dire avoir l'expérience pour ça fait
depuis l'âge de 15 ans qui fait de la
politique et que j'ai engagé dans le
milieu associatif
ça fait déjà 10 ans en fait que je j'ai
l'expérience si vous voulez si vous y
avez l'argument chaque fois du vieux
briscard
excusez moi du terme ces termes
d'emplois dans la à la maison c'est à
faux t'as pas assez de notoriété tapas
et l'expérience c'est les phrases
classique qu'on entend quand on a quand
on a 26 ans et qu'on est engagé en
politique jean philippe dugoin clément
sur ces aspects là voilà pour moi trois
choses je crois le la défiance par
rapport à l'âge c'est quelque chose
c'est une idée reçue ça n'existe plus
aujourd'hui à mites élections de macron
c'est la preuve qu'il ya une volonté de
renouvellement
moi je pourrais vous donner des exemples
de mer en essonne qui ont été lus à
moins de 30 ans et dont par un électorat
beaucoup plus âgés qu'eux donc cette
question de l'âge pour moi c'est pas une
barrière électorale pour moi les deux
barrières elles sont différentes c'est
vraiment ce que vous disiez il ya
quelques minutes c'est le parcours de
vie et la politique est quelque chose
qui est complètement chronophage qui
manche dimanche sur la vie familiale qui
mangent sur les activités personnelles
qui mangent sur les activités
professionnelles
les gens ne mesurent assez peu avant de
s'y frotter saïfi au passage le manque
de femmes 1 que pointer un soir et quand
on est à moins de 40 45 ans quand on est
dans une phase de construction de sa vie
arrivé à dégager du temps pour un
engagement public politique c'est
extrêmement dur
et puis la troisième chose ce que disait
le grand père ça a été coupée juste
c'était la phrase suivante c'est un
milieu qui est extrêmement dur quand
vous êtes engagé en politique vous
prenez énormément de coups vous
votre autre votre entourage et souvent
c'est plus dur pour l'entourage direct
que pour vous et c'est quelque chose qui
rebute aussi parce que faut avoir
conscience que faire de la politique
c'est pas non plus uniquement les images
plutôt sympa qu'on a vu dans ce
reportage
avec cet élu qui découvrent qu'ils
portent des dossiers c'est aussi on l'a
vu un petit peu au début quand il ya un
syndicaliste qui le prend à partie mais
c'est ce genre de choses c'est être
confronté aussi au dur c'est de
confronter à la détresse des gens c'est
être confronté à la colère des gens
c'est de confronter à des situations où
on n'a pas forcément de réponses à
apporter
et on est un petit peu l'exutoire des
colères et je crois que quand on met ces
deux facteurs là c'est beaucoup plus
quelque chose qui constitue un barrage
que le fait d'être éligible ou crédibles
ou bankable pour prendre un anglais et
un anglicisme du fait de son âge
camille etienne j'aimerais bien vous
faire réagir à ce qu'on entend parce que
vous avez un engagement je pas si on
peut le qualifier de politique en tout
cas qu'est militants qui est différent
vous n'avez pas rendre compte de vos
actions
devant devant des électeurs comment
est-ce que vous réagissez voilà 7 à ce
qu'on vient d'entendre sur locaux sur la
protée de l'engagement politique
je suis aussi en étant est ce que je
sais c'est la politique par ascendant
hémicycle où au sein de jeu pas elle lui
évidemment mais mais quelque part chez
lui par tous les gens qui me suivent
donc qui me soutiennent et qui est qui
soutiennent les actions et qui me
rejoignent c'est à dire que là
aujourd'hui compte on décide à saint
camille de se planter devant tous les
jours devant l'assemblée nationale la
loi climat et que mon petit à petit sa
mort en a de plus en plus de monde pour
une prise de presse et qu'on arrive à
avoir un impact sur certaines décisions
bah ça marche pour moi c'est comme ça
c'est une sorte de révocabilité c'est à
dire que le jour il ya plus personne qui
vient avec on reste cinq amis devant
international on aura absolument aucun
impact
donc quelque part a hélas mon élection
maintenant pour la difficulté oui c'est
d'ailleurs je pense une des raisons qui
me fait chi qui fait que j'ai pas envie
de faire la politique parce que c'est
déjà pas du tout évident rien dans ma
position de me prendre des vannes de
haine et de haters quotidiennement les
réseaux sociaux permettent cette
violence de manière démultiplie d'autres
d'autres d'autres joies et donc donc
clairement mais je pense pas avoir les
épaules pour faire ça parce que je suis
très sensible dans le sens où où je
pense que pour s'engager sur ces
questions écologiques il faut avoir
aussi une sensibilité à ce monde et à
l'injustice elle pourfend la politique
aussi peut-être même et du coup il ya
une sorte de tension qui est peut-être
pas réconciliables mais du coup non bien
sûr qu'il faut beaucoup de courage et en
plus de ça il faut une intransigeance
il faut une intransigeance absolue à mon
sens et c'est ce que j'essaie de pousser
à chaque fois que je peux rencontrer des
élus de dire ne vous laissez pas
endormir par par aussi des lobbys qui
l'ont bien d'esprit à ce qu'on avait que
cette loi climat qui n'ont aucun intérêt
à essayer de toujours toujours toujours
faire passer la vie des gens à prendre
un congrès et que ça va être très
compliqué bien comment j'ai de
l'admiration pour ceux qui le prend avec
intransigeance
bien sûr vous laissez pas endormir et
mick armand est ce que vous avez parfois
l'impression que c'est bon de vous
laisser un peu endormir par le système
j'allais dire de vieillir un peu avant
l'âge d'un an voilà du fait de
deux de ces institutions qui sont
lourdes outre sa place vous trouvez
aussi qu'est ce qu'on veut faire de son
mandat par rapport à ce qu'on a raconté
dans la campagne et donc ça c'est aussi
et les engagements qu'on a qu'on a
défendu pendant la campagne qu'il faut
prolonger maintenant dans les six ans
donc ça c'est voilà j'essaie de toujours
de me référer par rapport à ce que j'ai
écrit dans mon document dans mon projet
de huit pages et j'essaie de l'appliquer
tout simplement pendant ces six ans et
aussi de bien neuf ans au fil de
l'actualité aussi parce qu'on on dépend
aussi de l'actualité mais en tout cas
voilà moi je
j'ai voulu parler en faire une
profession loi sur l'extension du rsa
jeunes au sénat ben j'ai fait avec le
groupe socialiste on a déposé une
provision voix le 20 janvier dernier
oui enfin n'a pas été adopté qui n'a pas
été adoptée forcément passer ça c'est ce
qu'on veut c'est ce qu'on vous dira on
grave voilà finalement oui le débat et
s'est installé dans le grand public
vous voyez donc c'est pas du temps de
perdu ça renvoie un mot qui a été
employé par camille etienne et sur
lequel je voulais vous interrogez
laurent lardeux c'est le mot impact
souvent quand les jeunes disent voilà
moi la politique ça m'intéresse assez de
la politique partisane l'élection at il
dit si mal manger plus d'impact en
engageant sur les réseaux sociaux
est-ce que c'est pas une des causes du
désintérêt des jeunes pour la politique
partisane
laurent lardeux alors c'est vrai que
déjà il ya un désenchantement politique
qu on observe au niveau de la
participation politique traditionnelle
classique on doit notamment à travers
l'abstention par un niveau de défiance
qui est très important d avis du
personnel politique mais par contre
c'est très important de le souligner ce
désenchantement politique dans un cadre
institutionnel pas aussi étroitement
s'articuler avec un réenchantement
démocratique
les nouvelles générations par un
investissement plus important dans des
actions politiques hors des institutions
politiques traditionnels que ce soit à
travers des démarches des manifestations
des pétitions des boycotts et est ce que
l'on constate d'abord vincent tiberi le
montre très bien dans les ouvrages que
nous avons co dirigé sur le sujet c'est
qu'il ya une déconnexion en fait les
connexions très forte de plus en plus
forte entre les valeurs des jeunes
citoyens qui sont bien présentes très
affirmée notamment en termes de justice
sociale d'égalité d'environnement et
l'offre politique qui leur est proposé
et cette déconnexion là qui les incite
finalement a aussi aller chercher
d'autres
s'impliquer dans le débat public plus en
phase avec leur lors de heurts
et pourtant là nous tournons vers vous
jean philippe dugoin clément c'est pas
la même chose d'avoir une opinion la
défendre sur les réseaux sociaux
éventuellement dans des manifestations
dans la rue et d'assumer un mandat de
prendre
vous disiez de prendre des coups de
prendre des décisions tout simplement et
puis ensuite d'en rendre compte devant
les électeurs c'est deux choses
différentes
ces deux choses différentes qui peuvent
être complémentaires mais c'est l'un
pouvant amener à l'autre mais c'est
effectivement deux choses différentes
d'une manière générale ce n'est pas
spécifique aux jeunes mais on est quand
même dans une société où beaucoup
beaucoup de gens consomment plus qu'il
ne s'implique c'est la première chose et
beaucoup de joueurs s'impliquent de
manière souvent un peu light au travers
des phénomènes de réseaux sociaux parce
que c'est beaucoup plus simple on like
on est on donne un avis mais au fond on
n'agit pas véritablement et l'engagement
qu'ils soient associatifs qui soit
syndicale qu'ils soient politiques
passés à la phase d'engagement quel que
soit le domaine
là c'est un cap supplémentaire je vous
coupe mais c'est intéressant parce que
souvent c'est le reproche qu'on vous
fait c'est vous vous n'agissez pas
véritablement moi finalement j'ai plus
d'impact ça me fait penser à une la
phrase d'un élu un jour qui devait être
un peu déprimé mais qui me disait orb
finalement j'ai - jay moins d'impact sur
la vie des gens que certains
influenceurs sur youtube mais s'ils
pensent qu'il n'a pas d'impact fois
qu'il fasse autre chose
le jour où moi j'aurais pu en ville
d'omagh sur le jour où je me mettrai
plus en colère le jour où j'aurai pas
envie le samedi matin plutôt que de
dormir d'aller faire une permanence
samedi après-midi de marier des gens
leleu des dettes d'aller me bagarrer
pour porter les dossiers de ma commune
ou de ma région
effectivement faudrait que j'arrête que
je fasse autre chose le jour un élu
pense qu'il a plus d'impact qui ne sert
à rien d'acquis fasse autre chose là
dessus sur la question de l'impact
rémy chardon vous avez vraiment
l'impression avoir de l'impact mais tout
à fait d'ailleurs figure et vous quand
on parle dans certains médias ça peut
prendre parfois des proportions énormes
sur le grand public donc il faut faire
attention il faut aussi bien évidemment
dire ce qu'on pense clairement sans
avoir d'hésitation sans avoir de voix là
de peur de représailles il faut assumer
aussi parfois ses valeurs ce que je
ressens aussi ces cas puisque moi j'ai
vu l'évolution entre les militants et
les militants si vous voulez il ya une
j'ai l'âge de 15 ans je voyais les
militants très hardie entre le collage
le boîtage fine une en soif de 2 voilà
deux d'aller dans la rue d'aller
discuter en porte à porte etc et la
petit à petit au fil des années on a
effectivement un peu plus de
consommation de personnes de militants
qui sont plutôt habile avec le numérique
et du coup qui sont là plutôt pour
consommer partager laïque et et pas
forcément aller plus loin le rang d'art
2 ça c'est une évolution j'imagine que
vous avez constaté vous parlez de votre
votre livre tout à leur génération des
gens désenchantés c'est quelque chose
que vous constatez oui tout à fait c'est
très important de soutenir la défiance
ne signifie pas prise de distance ou
dessaisissement politique au contraire
en fait c'est à dire que les jeunes
citoyens les plus critiques vis-à-vis de
leurs régimes politiques tendent aussi
avoir une vision plus exigeantes de la
démocratie et donc il s'éloigne aussi
d'une conception de la démocratie qui
sera imité finalement ou aux simples
bottes et d'autres dimensions des ronds
tâches ordinaires des principes
d'égalité de réduction des inégalités
notamment c'est un élément qui revient
très souvent
donc il ya un souhait partagé aussi
impliqué dans cette démocratie mais dans
des configurations profondément
renouvelé plus directe et moins
dépendante des structures politiques
traditionnels c'est un point très
intéressant sur lequel je voudrais vous
entendre camille etienne parce que c'est
un reproche qu'on fait souvent à la
génération d attenberg qui voilà qui dit
finalement signé une pétition ça a plus
de poids que de voter simplement voilà
aujourd'hui ce sont pas ceux sont pas
les règles démocratiques qu'est ce que
vous répondez à cette critique est la
réponse très dire c'est que on a besoin
de tout le monde faut arrêter de croire
qu'il ya une méthode mieux que les
autres parce que ce serait fait il faut
retrouver l'humilité d'une unité claire
keim de la terre ont retrouvé un
écosystème d'action c'est aussi cet
écosystème on est en train de détruire
donc pour moi absolument tout est
nécessaire absolument tout est
nécessaire parce qu'on a besoin aussi de
creissels ce contre pouvoir n'a besoin
d'être et lombaires canton niveau
emballant la contre démocratie c'est ça
aussi c'est c'est pas il faut vraiment
pas confondre un désintérêt de la
politique comme on peut l'entendre
la politique et le politique fin sans
faire de com on pourrait de manière
traditionnelle on va dire pour égaliser
et l'engagement pour des idées un peu
plus tranquille mais si on reprend
politique au sens de police la gestion
de la cité mais la jeunesse elle et elle
est extrêmement mêmes fins c'est le
jeune n'a pas non plus trop qu'on
enferme dans une tranche d'âge un moyen
d'action mais mais mais regardez comme
la société française elle se réveille on
a eu des milliers de personnes dans les
rues des vignes et de personnes qui
s'engagent qui sont en train de créer
des peuples un chaussant voilà on se
saisit de questions beaucoup plus grande
que nous-mêmes et on a envie d'être
impliqué dans la décision
maintenant moi donc je serais vraiment
jolie à deux points très rapidement
c'est la méfiance dans nos institutions
démocratiques aujourd'hui quand on a un
président pour la pour des exemples
concrets sur la convention citoyenne
pour le climat qui s'engagent à faire
passer en sans filtre et maintenant avec
les vidéos on à emmanuel raconte il me
dit on faire passer un sans filtre donc
des gens y vont moi je me suis
énormément investi sur cette convention
citoyenne j'ai fait en sorte que plein
de gens parce qu'il faut savoir
beaucoup des ong etc si t'es pas
forcément parce qu'elle avait cette
méfiance est bon et c'est d'embarquer
tout bon pour dire ça va être génial ça
peut être un moment où l'éthique
démocratique fort et on avance vers des
solutions compte derrière c'est
complètement balayées d'un revers de
main évidemment quand on dit tout ça
pour ça en fait non c'est ton peu plus
on peut plus avoir confiance dans cette
représentation l'art de la même manière
pour la loi climat pour la loi climat
qui était censée transmettre ces
mesures-là commençons citoyenne on se
retrouve avec des élus et non on a passé
trois semaines devant la mesure en
retrait un certain s'il y avait vraiment
des idées de faire changer les choses de
manière radicale qui se retrouvait
complètement bloquée en fac dans leur
idée parce que on avait en articles 5 10
et habilités des amendements ont été
utilisés à outrance on avait des biens
industriels qui faisait tout pour
ralentir
l'ambition de cette loi donc en fait moi
je là je me fais l'avocat du diable ici
en doit en public de cm2 cros crise de
confiance dans notre musique parce que
c'est important qu'on s'en saisissent
sinon on n'a jamais bougé
donc je suis super fier je suis très
heureuse que des gens comme vous qu'elle
pourrait égaler des poils de jeunes et
nouveaux
toujours intransigeant des fois j'allais
tout ça et c'est fondamental mais il
faut aussi comprendre sans
condescendance les gens disent mal un
moment donné alors là dessus jean
philippe dugoin clément vous comme maire
voilà dieu à mennecy dans l'essonne
est ce que les personnes qui s'engagent
comme ça sur les réseaux sociaux
j'imagine qu'il y en a à l'échelle
locale évidemment est ce qu'elle vous
rendre service est ce qu'elle vous agace
c'est ce qu'elle vous mordre les mollets
vous stimule n'ont ni l'un ni l'autre ça
fait partie d'un écosystème bourse qui
est très fort il ya beaucoup changé ce
qui est très frustrant sur les réseaux
sociaux section c'est extrêmement
réducteur et expliquer quelque chose de
complexe avec un nombre de signes limité
c'est extrêmement compliqué et la
difficulté dans la gestion publique des
réseaux sociaux c'est de manière
simpliste de répondre à des choses
souvent un peu caricatural sol sans
mentir sur tronqué les mets sur le point
précis que soulevait camille etienne sur
la complémentarité possible entre voilà
la société civile et les aimait lui mais
tout ça c'est évidemment c'est un autre
de tous c'est complémentaire parce qu'en
fait la politique l'engagement public
c'est quoi c'est défendre des opinions
c'est défendez point de vue c'est
défendre des idées qui parfois sont
contradictoires qui peuvent créer des
sites phénomène d'insatisfaction quand
se comportent soi même ce qu'on défend
soi même la proposition de loi qu'on a
porté le combat comporte n'est pas
entendue mais tout ça au fond c'est quoi
c'est l'engagement individuel des
citoyens sous différentes formes et ses
formes là bas c'est l'engagement
militant politique c'est l'engagement
associatif c'est l'engagement syndical
on le retrouve sous différents axes
laurent l'art de frais qu'on parle des
réformes puisqu'on a on a évoqué avec
qu'elles détiennent le fait que les
institutions étaient parfois sclérosé
comment est-ce qu'on s'y prend à
l'avenir pour faire en sorte que les
jeunes participent plus activement à la
vie de la cité
si c'est une question extrêmement
compliqué parce que c'est vrai que comme
c'est cela qu'on a plutôt tendance à
observer la situation sociale et après
par contre on relève aussi des attentes
et des demandes et aspirations des
jeunes et c'est plutôt sur ces points là
qu'on peut relayer des informations et
il ya plus
des attentes en termes de d'une
meilleure circulation effectivement
entre des logiques très partisane de la
politique traditionnelle et puis
d'autres plus alternatives
effectivement on est trop tendance à
scinder ces deux dimensions alors que
y'a vraiment des des attentes des deux
côtés sans doute de meilleure
articulation ricard dont il ya des
choses à inventer justement pour mieux
articuler ses différentes formes
d'action publique
il faut plutôt favorisé le participatif
et aux consuls tf1 à la consultation
parce que ça c'est en tout cas faut
mettre embarquer les jeunes les moins
jeunes dans dans des dans des projets et
il ya des jeunes qui sont prêts à
s'engager ça c'est certain
à partir de quel âge d'ailleurs ce que
en parle de la politique voilà à partir
de 10 villes en a il est mais je vous
étiez engagé à partir des jeunes à 14
ans 15 ans ils sont déjà très voilà très
très demandeur d'ailleurs petite
parenthèse droits de vote à partir de 16
ans pour les élections locales puisque
le débat revient quand même
régulièrement pas pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas si ça peut créer des débats des plus
jeune âge oui oui notre windows après
c'est objectivement prem's et c'est pas
d'avoir un droit c'est de l'exercer ce
qui est important c'est pas le droit en
tant que telle celle envie de se battre
pour laurent l'art deux petites
questions sur l'engagement associatif
puisqu'on parlait avec camille etienne
de la manière dont elle s'investit
notamment à travers ses engagements dans
les associations les ong
est-ce qu'il mène est-ce que c'est pas
aussi une manière de d'aller vers
l'engagement politique
on le voit de plus en plus des
personnalités qui s'engagent dans les
ong qui vont vers la politique ou
d'ailleurs linverse je pense à cécile
duflot notamment
alors oui c'est vrai qu'il ya posit est
très forte entre le domaine associatif
et domaine politique d'ailleurs on le
voit aussi sur l'encart que nous avons
mené sur les jeunes mères c'est à dire
qu'on va beaucoup de
je mer ou de jeunes élus municipaux de
façon plus générale qui sont passés par
la boîte social ti vct pour ensuite
effectivement briguer un mandat ou
encore une fois pour se sentir autorisé
aussi à briguer un mandat jean philippe
dugoin clément on ne fait pas de
politique
sous quelque forme que ce soit si on n'a
pas une envie d'aller vers l'autre de
changer les choses chacun avec sa propre
vision du monde
là j'ai pas de jugement de valeur ou de
jugement politique mais c'est cette
envie d'aller vers l'autre et souvent
l'engagement associatif
enfin on va pas dans une association va
pas s'occuper de gens dans une
association va pas porter des sujets si
on n'a pas cette envie en soi et c'est
là où on a effectivement des
possibilités de porosité c'est aussi un
moyen d'avoir un pied à l'étrier
c'est commencé à s'engager pour les
autres sous différentes manières ça peut
être fait dans le domaine associatif ça
peut être fait dans le domaine syndical
également c'est pour moi c'est des
points de passage important mais le nom
d'ailleurs on a commencé par la vie
familiale comme lieu qui pourrait mettre
le pied à l'étrier la vie associative
donc aussi est un est un et le marocain
giresse et même la première le renard de
là dessus c'est peu et vous voilà est-ce
que c'est le numéro âgées parce que dans
les études des chiffres là dessus du
côté des jeunes
très clairement il ya un engagement très
présent et qui persiste depuis
maintenant plusieurs décennies là aussi
je sais pas si ça sera le numéro en tout
cas il y aura fera très une réduction
très forte en tout cas des jeunes et des
appétences très certaine pour le domaine
associatif et l'engagement les maires
quand ils vont construire une liste des
fois il repère quand même entre l'huile
et bien il s'occupe des parents d'élèves
de l'école lui il est très bien où elle
allait très bien aussi elle s'occupe de
deux du club de danse et ses terres par
un vivier de recrutement pour les
lisières et enfin j'ai l'impression pour
avoir jugé pas été maire mais je jouais
plutôt un prime ça fonctionne aussi
comme ça on va devoir les jeux juste le
mot de la fin pour camille etienne vous
avez été approché vous par par des élus
qui vous ont dit présentez-vous sur ma
liste
ou est ce que vous envisagez vous un
jour de vous présenter oui j'aime ses
devoirs j'ai plus envie
donc mon sens il faut qu'on arrive à
travailler ensemble et je réponds à
l'appel de tous les élus que je peux
rencontrer érection que discuter pourra
concrètement le
parce que c'est je pense qu'on a besoin
tout en faisant tant d'artistes
présentateur télé à la hauteur que
d'agriculteurs qui doit respecter aussi
que d'élus est pas mon rôle
les pousser ceux qui ne sentent cette
vocation ne à le faire et toujours et le
choeur avec intransigeance porter les
idées radicales que vous avez hauteur de
l'urgence climatique et sociale
merci beaucoup merci à tous les quatre
de nous avoir aidés à approfondir sur
cette thématique passionnante je renvoie
au livre que vous évoquiez laurent l'art
2 que vous avez écrit avec vincent
tiberi génération désenchantée jeunes et
politique paru au mois de mars dernier à
la documentation française merci à
toutes et à tous de nous avoir suivi et
à très bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]